the life of an entrepreneur
i got a question from eric who's one of
my readers who wrote in a huge long
email but basically wanted to know
i know you've been in business since you
were young how has it been
so that's a pretty wide-ranging question
uh
i started my business my first real
company when i was 19
and uh before then i had a whole bunch
of
little things on the side selling
baseball cards and a whole bunch of
different ventures
but the real company was when i was 19.
how has it been uh it's amazing
it's fun it's it's tons of highs and
it's also
frightening and scary and and
you doubt yourself constantly and tons
of lows as well you know it's part
the best part of my life in the worst
part of my life all wrapped into one
and i think any entrepreneur will can uh
can feel the same way i think you can uh
i don't know the word is you can you can
associate with it
maybe will help us to tell you the best
part and the worst part
in my business career the worst was when
i thought about quitting
in the early days of my software company
i had
two partners and and we thought things
would be great you know we thought
we had a great product people loved it
and we would
take over the world with our software uh
and it just never picked up like we
thought it would and things were so much
harder than we thought it would be
and and it's frustrating because you're
losing money you know i'm making 300
bucks a month that wasn't enough to
survive
i was frustrated and angry and and
lost that my confidence and didn't know
where to go with it and and thought
about
giving up on a daily basis um
the worst moment for me in all of that
mess
was i don't remember the day but i was
over at my parents house for a family
function
and i got a call from my business
partner and i took it upstairs
and we just we had struggled so much in
getting to this point and trying to
figure out how we would grow we both had
the same vision what we wanted to do but
but different plans and how
to get there and it got to the point
where i thought you know what this is
this is not working you know i i'm so
frustrated
i don't want to be there i don't want to
be in this business anymore i quit
you know you could buy my shares
whatever it is we'll figure it out but
i'm done i'm done with this company
i need to do something else where more
where my
talents and skills are being used
properly i want to have an impact
i'm done and i hung up the phone and i
cried for 15 minutes
just uncontrollably you know tears
running down my face
down my nose you know it's like i was a
i was a wreck
just a total wreck because i built i
spent so much time building this thing
you know i put so much of myself into it
barely sleeping to launch this company
and
we saw barely any progress it was so
disheartening and my mom came up and she
put her hand on my shoulder and
asked me what was wrong and i couldn't
even say anything you know i was just so
overwhelmed
i don't know if i responded at all
and i went to bed that night you know
cried myself to sleep
and the next day i got up and went back
to work
that's what you do that's what you do as
an entrepreneur
but that was that was the worst single
worst day in my life as an entrepreneur
the best day was when i sold my company
and that wasn't that far from when i
almost gave up you know it was only
two years in between that terrible day
where i almost quit to being acquired
and all the
crazy stuff that happened in between
and what kept me going was was the
passion for the business and feeling
like i was doing something right
and i wasn't doing it just for the money
i was doing it to do it and doing it to
have an impact and doing it to
to be part of something meaningful and
so
as an entrepreneur you have to be you
know willing and ready to ride that
roller coaster you're going to have
great highs when you feel on top of the
world you feel
invincible you feel like yeah this is
working finally you know
this is this is amazing and then
almost as quickly as feeling that
emotion you'll get you'll get hit in the
face with something
and it'll knock you down and you're in
full
crisis mode trying to solve this problem
and and just when you feel like things
couldn't get worse
another punch comes to the stomach and
and you you'll be tested beyond
beyond what you thought was possible
it'll be so bad
and it'll really test your character and
test
to see what you're made of and test how
much
you really love this business or not if
you're doing it for the right reasons or
not
and if you come out on the other side
it's because you're really super
passionate about this company
and not willing to give up so it was a
bit of a broad question so i gave you
kind of a broad answer but that's my
story in a nutshell
if you guys like the video please give
it a thumbs up below i love seeing us
come in and
if you have a specific question for me
or if you want to leave a comment leave
it below
i really love seeing those come in i
really appreciate it when you guys do
that
it really makes me want to keep doing
more of these videos for you
you guys inspire me to keep going so
please leave a comment underneath thank
you so much
and i'll see you soon
you